[Music]
very honest about your life you're very
honest about uh you know your
you know how you how you dress you're
honest about the fact that you wear wigs
you constantly wear wigs yes and you
call yourself a wiggy yes yes you say
you wear them everywhere dax can you
tell from this angle no way
no way
maybe no it's very
can you tell
i've been smelling it while you've been
talking
no i i i love completely fake i do that
for people i love when you do that's a
good trick i've seen you do that before
it's not a trick uh
this is polyurethane um
but you have a different wig for a
vacation you even have a
wig for the gym yes no a gym wig i think
we have a photograph of it there's your
gym wig well okay what's going on here
first of all when you go to the gym you
don't wear makeup second of all that
you look like the wendy's girl after she
saw a ghost well here's the problem
that that wig i know exactly what that
is so i didn't have my gym wig that day
but i had a bouffant and i took the
bouffant down the bouffant wig and i put
it in the two ponytails because when you
work out you don't want to sweat your
skin and the wigs and things like you
don't want to get your your wig caught
in the machinery of the gym no no or
caught on the sweat but there is a wig
for every occasion for instance um there
is a wig we have a 12 year old he's
going into seventh grade uh when i go
see his teachers i'm not all twirled up
with a big giant number on
you know you can pick the correct hair
for the correct occasion that's what i'm
a wig for every occasion what about for
a shower
a shower would be
if you put on you mean we're going to go
what about a roller coaster do you get a
wig that makes you look scared
no but you know what
you put that on you just promise a
cucumber i know how to fix my wigs so
that they stay on for roller coasters
and water rides and it's so funny we
took our kid last year for his
birthday's birthdays in august so it's
always fun to be outside and for his
11th birthday we went to a water park
well here's everybody at the there was
like nobody in line everybody wanted to
sit at the bottom and wait to see what
wendy's hair would look like when wendy
came down so what happened oh i had
something for them my wigs don't fall
off like that like what's your secret do
you have do you have surgery and there's
velcro in your skull i mean what do you
do
when you're not doing the talk show do
you do much to your own hair do you know
how yeah oh my god you it's people laugh
at me because i you know i'm serious
anyone could wake me up at like four in
the morning and it's just it's this
kooky thing i don't know what's going on
no one knows it shouldn't be about me it
should be about the guest let's talk
about that now